Stage one pressing for flight
how can I skip a person's life
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one
all right a lot of treatment as you just
saw Falcon 9 had an on-time liftoff
through the fog from Vandenberg Air
Force Base approaching max Q who is
supersonic
vehicle is passing through maximum
dynamic pressure
we now have three events coming up in
rapid succession main engine cutoff
stage separation and second engine start
one or ses one all of these things you
can follow along with on the timeline at
the bottom of your screen
main engine cutoff coming up soon this
is where all nine engines of f9 will
shut down trajectory is looking good
state stage and there on your screen you
can see that we a visual confirmation of
main engine cutoff stage separation and
second engine start one so on the left
hand side of your screen we'll watch the
first stage as it begins its return back
to Vandenberg Air Force Base on the
right-hand side of your screen you can
see the second engine as it begins to
carry the three radar satellites to
sun-synchronous orbit
so whose background has begun there you
just saw fairing deployment it's pretty
cool shot of the fairing flying away we
have about ten seconds left in the boost
back burn
so the shot you see on your left is from
it inside the interstage and through
spec confirmation of boosts back shut
down so in order for stable trajectory
make its way back to landing zone one at
Vandenberg Air Force Base it has to
execute a series of three burns the
first which you just saw is what we call
the boost back burn and that helps to
slow the rocket down and orient it for
entry
shortly after this the grid fins which
you see right there articulating as they
help steer the rocket back to Vandenberg
those are deployed to help guide the
rocket during its descent following that
Falcon 9 execute its entry burn and that
slows itself down before hitting the
dense part of the atmosphere
the entry burn actually cuts the
first-stage speed almost in half so
that's what will be coming up next at
about the t+ six-minute mark the third
and final burn that stage one will
execute today is the landing burn
happens to be everybody's favorite burn
and that takes place just before
touchdown as the booster touches down
softly on the ground so if you happen to
be in the greater Vandenberg Air Force
Base area I recommend that you head
outside because you are very likely in
range to experience the sonic boom that
comes with reentry
so at t plus five minutes now we have
confirmation that M back power is good
trajectories looking good
despite the foggy view from this morning
everything is looking good
we are ten seconds till entry burn
they started confirmation that stage one
entry burns has started so there on the
left-hand side of your screen you see
the first stage as it's making its way
back to landing zone one at Vandenberg
Air Force Base with the help of the grid
fins as it steers the view on your right
is the same operation that we have going
on just from a different camera so there
you can see that we have a confirmation
of the stable and the entry barn
shutdown
Stage two on the right hand side they're
looking good
everything is nominal and trajectory is
good
Stage one FTS s safe
slowly but surely you can see the layer
of fog re approaching on the left-hand
side as we have a view from the top of
the first stage rocket looking down the
rocket towards the engine section
section you heard the call out for stage
1 transonic landing burn has begun due
to the fog we might lose the video as it
touches down but stay tuned
okay
there you can see
[Applause]
[Music]
there you can see stage two again
through the fog but at least a little
bit more clearly this time Falcon 9 has
handed that landing zone one back at
Vandenberg Air Force Base so with that
good news we turn back into second stage
our primary missions as it continues to
carry the three radar sac constellation
satellites to Sun synchronous orbit
that's a shot of the EM vac nozzle as it
burns we go through and there we had
confirmation of second engine cutoff or
a Seco so now we're just gonna wait for
confirmation of second stage good orbit
J and C confirm is going to first
orbital insertion all right we have
confirmation that we have a good orbit
for a second stage now we're about to
enter a 40 minute Coast face so we're
gonna take a break but we're leaving you
with an animation that shows where we
are in the co space we'll be back at
about t plus 49 and a half minutes for a
second stage radio signal Vandenberg is
expecting also signal Hawthorne as
expected
[Music]